en plena madrugada explotó un dron sobre
el kremlin
en un supuesto ataque contra el
presidente de Rusia Vladimir Putin a
pocos días del día de la Victoria el 9
de mayo un ataque por el que las fuentes
oficiales acusaron directamente a
Ucrania
Moscú considera el atentado contra la
residencia del presidente como un acto
terrorista planificado y un intento de
asesinato contra el jefe de estado el
kremlin aseguró que se usaron dos drones
en el supuesto ataque contra Putin pero
al acercarse a la ciudadela murallada
fueron desactivados tras los hechos Kid
ha negado de plano cualquier implicación
en el asunto
no atacamos a Putin o a Moscú luchamos
en nuestro territorio estamos
defendiendo nuestros pueblos y ciudades
no tenemos ya sabes suficientes armas
para esto
por eso no lo usamos en ningún lado para
nosotros es un déficit
ahora tanto que como la comunidad
internacional también posibles
represalias y países como Estados Unidos
han pedido que no se escale la situación
y cuestionado la credibilidad del ataque
he visto los informes no puedo
validarlos de ninguna manera Simplemente
no podemos saberlo
y dijimos que Ucrania decida cómo
defenderse Y tratar de Recuperar el
territorio arrebatado
tras lo sucedido el kremlin ha asegurado
haber abierto una investigación a
terrorista sobre lo sucedido al tiempo
que reforzará la seguridad de cara al 9
de mayo